nicaraguan soldiers police and
sandinista party supporters came out
bright and early to vote but in most of
the country the streets and the usually
bustling polling stations were empty
this was in response to a call to
boycott an election in which all the
competitive opposition candidates were
imprisoned or disqualified from running
foreign journalists were barred from
entering the country to cover the voting
president daniel ortega and his wife
rosario murillo the vice president
nevertheless hailed the election as fair
free and democratic
ortega then described opponents and
their alleged foreign backers as
terrorists
they are demons demons who do not want
peace who do not want tranquility for
our country they opt for violence for
war for slander for campaigns for what
so that nicaragua is once again plunged
into violent confrontations
aula lilia lopez is one of the many who
did not vote still in mourning for her
21 year old son gaitan whom she says was
murdered by ortega security forces
during an anti-government protest
there's been no justice because you know
how we are with the ortega-moreya regime
for them these victims don't exist there
have been no murders or political
prisoners
[Music]
while public protests have been outlawed
in nicaragua in neighboring costa rica
thousands of nicaraguan refugees marched
to denounce what they insisted was a
farce
what daniel ortega has organized is a
political circus that's why we are
dressed as clowns to mock his circus we
continue crying out for justice for all
those he has killed since taking power
at least another eight government
critics were reportedly arrested in
nicaragua before the polls opened many
of the exiles say they were forced to
flee their country here into costa rica
as exiles so that they wouldn't end up
like these people who are among the more
than 300 nicaraguans who were killed by
police or paramilitary groups during the
2018 uprising now many nicaraguans are
asking the international community to
step up to the plate
the u.s government is expected to
announce stronger sanctions against the
ortega government shortly while the eu
says it's considering what action to
take to put further pressure on the
government
as for the election results with all the
competitive opposition candidates behind
bars the poll was never about who would
get the most votes but rather about mr
and mrs ortega's permanence in power
lucia newman al jazeera san jose costa
rica well tiziano breda is a central
america analyst at the international
crisis group and he says one major
concern about these elections is that
they're happening in a police state
but also on the other side you have
these opposition movements which are in
complete disarray and over the past few
years uh have not managed to
nurture what was the spirit of the h2018
mass protest movements and not
prioritizing the demands of social and
political change that these movements uh
brought forward
which is also somehow disillusioned um
and deceived a lot of nicaraguans um so
it will be this election would not be a
test uh only for ortega to see how many
people will actually show up uh to vote
for him but also for the for the
opposition movements to actually show if
they still have a sway
over the population the country's
socio-political crisis is actually
unsustainable and it has led to has
prompted a strong economic recession
over the past few years just partly uh
recovering this year
but mostly thanks to a global trend in
boost of the economy uh and a lot of
resources that have been funneled
through nicaragua but five more years of
our government actually results from
basically a one-sided poll
will unlikely
result first of all uh the lack of the
legitimacy that he has internally and
internationally and it will definitely
chase away um a foreign dire investment
and will hardly get a hold of
international loans so the combination
of this sort of continued uh or deepen
isolation internationally and repression
internally will definitely first of all
prompt more and more nicaraguans to
leave the country and not only to costa
rica which was the traditional
destination country but increasingly
also to the us